Hey, what's going on? Hey,
what's going on? Sorry,
I didn't know if this thing was on or not.
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, January seven,
2018 what's going on? How are Ya? Um,
it's fucking three 32
in the morning and uh,
I slept a little bit,
but just pen,
having a motherfucker of a time with this
jet lag over here and you know why it
is. It's cause I'm not boozing. Okay.
This one's for all you
alcoholics out there.
I'm fucking with you.
People keep telling me to go get Melatonin
and send natural way to get tired.
Um, all I know is the unnatural way
to get tired, tired, which was uh,
what I always did was just the first
night I tried to stay up and then I'd go
out and I would just go get,
I'd go booze,
I didn't have four fucking stiff
drinks and just come home and pass out.
And then I'd start to get
acclimated to their time.
I'd have to do that about three nights
in a row and then I was fine. Um,
so whatever.
I just been a,
so I got to do this fucking
podcast because today I'm
getting on a plane and I'm
flying to Estonia to do one show tonight.
I'm very excited about it. I
googled some pictures. First of all,
Astonia Jesus Christ.
What a Badass flag.
That's one of those things that I collect.
I don't buy a lot of touristy shit,
so I just get those little flags so I
gotta make sure I get the time to go down
and pick one of those. Um, then
I got lot via the next day.
This is the part of the tour where
I start going to all these places.
I've never been to as far
as countries goes. But, um,
the last two nights I started in
Cologne. I'd been there before. Um,
we did Munich on Saturday and yesterday
we did often back often Bach and um,
it's just been a fucking great time
being over here with [inaudible]. Sorry,
my voice is going through,
you know,
I'm trying to make sure you have
good shows and I don't know.
I don't know what the
fuck I did to it. But, uh,
yesterday I should say Saturday
and Sunday we had two shows,
Munich to and often buck.
And the first fucking
show was like at 3:30 PM.
This is what kills me.
I've,
I've never in my career that I can really
remember ever gone on stage like that.
I mean at that time,
I think maybe one time I was doing
hilarious and Cleveland and I did an
afternoon show, but I think that was at
like four or five, I dunno, just three 30.
It was fucking weird. But I got to
tell you, the crowd was unbelievable.
Munich crowds were fucking ridiculous.
I mean, they've all been great,
but they were just like,
we went like this,
I swear to God that felt it
goes on like a little and um,
it was like snowing out and I had to walk
from the green room back outside into
the snow and then back into the venue.
And I was just like,
these motherfuckers are
trying to get me sick.
So my coat on by big stupid palm
plum hat that I got in Finland,
where back in the day, which has been
saving my ass, that the vitamins,
seed packets and a bowl shows,
the crowds were just crazy
good. And, uh, in between shows,
I ran around trying to find my diaries,
some sneakers, some course sneakers.
I have found this store called early,
somebody told me about, and uh,
we drove over there and I bought
a couple pairs of sneakers.
I go to the forest Gump once, you
know, the classic Nike Cortez.
And I made sure that I got the,
uh,
the Velcro straps so she can get a
little fat fucking toddler feeding their,
you know,
um,
but it's pretty fucking cool because
in the middle of the city they had this
giant, just giant war going on, you
know, and it couldn't see how it could,
we just literally drove by and it
was the original wall of the city,
um, for like back in the day when
there was just like, you know,
it was a free for all.
You just sit in your village and all
of a sudden some fucking assholes would
just show up and just start murdering
the men and rape in the women in Layton,
shit on fire. And it was just like,
like that's what people did back then.
Like that was like a fucking like
something that someone aspired to.
They aspired to rape and pillage
and he just fucking lunatic shit.
So these people, you
know, wanted to survive.
So they would build these giant walls,
I guess around their fucking villages.
And then someone's trying to tell me a
till the hun used to save the bodies from
the previous village and then he'd sneak
up on a village he'd liked the body's
on fire and then with like a catapult,
which starts shooting them into the
fucking village, he wanted to attack.
Like you just sitting there chilling out,
enjoying yourself and like all the sudden,
you know,
I dunno what was the job back then?
Some fucking coppersmith comes through
the top of your fucking little hut.
They're on fire and lands on
your goddamn dinner table.
And that that was,
that was the first sign that your life
was going to fucking change. I mean,
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's crazy.
And I don't know what it is about Europe
maybe because I watched all this shit
about World War II and it, you know, and
a lot of, you know, American history,
they don't give a fuck about,
um,
you know, the whole curriculum was
designed by white descendants from Europe.
So that's all we fucking talked about.
So you just know certain shit.
And of course they, you know,
they dance around a lot of shit.
Um, but as I've been opening, I go,
when we took the train from fucking
Munich up to often Bach, uh,
they were like, next stop,
like Nurenberg. And I'm like,
Norenberg like Nuremberg trials.
For some reason I thought that that was,
those trials weren't France.
And now that I'm getting exposed a little
more to the German language, I'm like,
well, obviously that's not
a fucking French city. Um,
so I'm on the train and I'm
texting version to be like, dude,
this is where they fucking tried all
the Nazis, the SS and the Gestapo.
And Shit after World
War II when they like,
they'd like fucking put him to death and
shit hanging them and everything and uh,
um, texted him and he can't fucking,
yeah, he's not getting service.
So Mike Vaters II and he looks up,
you know, he's a couple seats away,
you know, but out of the
respect for German people, I
don't want to be like, hey,
this is where they fucking killed all
the Nazis have to function in World War
Two. I walked over to him
and I started to say it,
but because I'm speaking English,
people just look at you like all these
a fucking American, let's judge him.
Is he fat? Is he breathing through
his mouth? You know, was he loud?
So I just literally had
to show him the text. Um,
yeah.
And I'm sitting here, you know,
like when you go to fucking Berlin,
that's where Hitler killed himself
in part of his bunker. Still exist.
I know they didn't, they fucking
destroyed most of it. Soviets did.
And then they build just like an
apartment building around it. You know,
it's like Los Angeles,
how they do that shit. Um,
they just knocked shit down and they
don't give a fuck what happened.
And I get it. Cause the guy was so fucking
evil. But like, I'm just like, wow,
it's so fucking crazy that people,
the German people just walk amongst
all of this shit. And then I was like,
wait a minute.
I live in the United States of America.
I go down to south all the time.
I can't imagine what the fuck happened
right where I'm sitting when I'm sitting
in a fucking waffle house.
Like if that used to be like a plantation
or some slave was running away and
they got caught and God
knows what the fuck happened,
forget about the native Americans.
So I was like, well, why the fuck
do I only think about that shit you
don't like every time I go to Paris,
like when I look at this, Sean's
Elisa, that fucking street,
I just pictured when the Nazis
fucking paraded up the damn thing,
uh, when they occupied their
country and when the allied forces,
when they took it back.
Um,
and then all the French ladies banged
a bunch of Americans evidently. Um,
how come I don't think of that shit,
my own country.
It's just cause cause I
grew up then it's fucked.
I always thought that
would be like a weird
willow cy five fucking movies
slash horror movies that um,
I don't know if you just,
if you get them because they kind of
do what they do it on like light shit.
Like if you move into a house and someone
got murdered there in the 20s, right?
Like let me tell something. She, I'm going
to select you from fucking [inaudible].
Right. Then all of a sudden that
place is haunted. They don't wait.
Maybe American horror story did it.
I don't fucking know. I watch sports,
but um, anyway, um,
and then,
then I'm reading all of this shit and
it's like about the Nuremberg trial when
I'm on the fucking train and making sure
nobody's looking over my shoulder and
I'm seeing how like a,
they had to decide how they were going
to go sort of like the first time I think
of World War One,
they tried to do it,
but this is the first time
they were trying to make
people pay for their fucking
war crimes.
So you know,
FDR and fucking Churchill and all
these guys are trying to figure out how
they're going to go about doing it.
And FDR balked at something and then
he died and then Truman came in and was
just like, well wait a minute.
Yeah. Truman came in and was like,
no, we're going to do that shit. So he
must have still been at war with Japan.
And then he goes and he drops to fucking
nuclear weapons on fucking Japan.
Like it was, it's like they were
all fucking world war criminals.
We sit in there firebomb
and Dresden and shit.
It's like women and children down
there. It's, it's, so, I don't know.
That's why I always say like,
to this day,
I can't believe that like
war is still a legal,
you know,
slash like glorified and uh,
I mean, I understand defending
your country and shit like that.
If there's a fucking lunatic out there,
but like, you know, who's kidding?
Hope you know a lot. You know,
there's been a lot of iffy decisions
made out there for, you know,
it's just, it's a fucking land grab.
You're going after oil, you know, you,
you want, you want that land because it's,
it's got some water around it. I mean,
that's why people go to fucking war most
of the time it seems nowadays. Anyways.
Um, but anyways, I don't know.
Some of that leads to me
yeah.
To talking about fucking thin privilege.
I follow this Guy Yonis Papa's
on the Instagram. He's like,
fucking genius does all these characters
and stuff. So I'm always watching him.
Cal Dunnigan uh, Jeff Richards. I like
my favorite, like the fucking characters.
They do the fucking geniuses,
right? So I was watching his end,
he posted something about at some going,
what the fuck is then privilege?
I already know I have white privilege.
Evidently I have been privileged to like
if it was like monopoly and there was a
stretch, a little properties that
were the privileged properties.
Like I feel like I got some of those
little green houses on a lot of them.
So evidently it's a privilege to be
thin rather than a reward for having the
discipline to push yourself away from
the fucking table. You know? And I'm not,
I'm not talking about when
you were a kid and you just,
some people have baby fell like I
baby fat. I was a fat fucking kid.
I was like 10 pounds. You
know, when I was born,
I was a big fucking read Charlie
Brown looking fucking baby.
There's not one cute picture of me till
I'm like three in my head was literally
almost the size it is right now.
When I was at adult.
Like I literally from day one look like
I could fuck up a Lego city. Right.
And, um, you know,
by just use that to my advantage that'd
be on the playground and people be
fucked with me cause my orange hair and
I just lean on him, you know, like a,
like a boxer that just wear him out in
the early rounds. And then I just fucking,
you know,
bunch of body shots and it would be over
me with my big flabby freckled arms.
And then somewhere in like junior high,
I just sort of leaned out.
My goal was Sunday,
grew a little bit and uh,
and then I stopped growing and
then I was just a small skinny kid.
I kind of had it all, you know,
when it comes to the bullying,
I was a fat kid when I was
real young then I was, uh,
but I was big and then I became small
and I was skinny and you throw it all in
there.
I had orange hair,
so it was kind of inevitable that I was
going to end up being some sort of a
fucking comedian or something. I
don't know what. But, um, anyways,
this then privileged shed.
It's like they like people who are
thin need to fucking acknowledge.
You know, it's up to you to realize
how privileged you are that, you know,
people don't judge you when
you eat a cookie in public
and blah, blah, blah, blah.
And all the cities like,
well,
go to the fucking judge me when I put
on a pair of shorts and look at our
fucking white, my legs are,
you know, these fucking people.
You know what kills me about shit
like that. All right, I get it.
Where you shouldn't tease fed people
and make them feel bad and all that,
you know, it's fucking immature
and it's me, I get it. Right?
But on the other side,
it's like there's no,
there's no burden of responsibility.
It's something that's
totally fucking curable.
And I know some people literally have
like food addictions and like it's a
psychological thing or whatever. But
you know, for most people who have fat,
it's just, you've just eaten
too much fucking food, you know?
And considering most of the
goddamn world is starving.
You know, it's just like, if,
can you underscore believe that
with this train of thought,
fat white people in a first world nation
can literally walk around and call
themselves victims? Well, you know,
I don't know all of these
fucking fatties I swear to God,
that's why I did that bid
on it at my last special.
You need to go to some countries where
the people are really have some problems.
I mean, you can even go to score on
the fucking Internet and read about it.
You can fill a hell of a lot fucking
better about yourself. You know,
I was sitting there, uh, you know, I was
getting frustrated with being fucking, uh,
jet lagged and Shit in these three 30
in the afternoon show is, I was like,
fuck man,
now I can't fucking sleep.
And I was like feeling like I was a Zombie
and I was getting old grumpy and shit.
And then like I go on the Internet
and I'm like, wait a minute. Okay.
So if Nuremberg is here, where was
Auswitch also, I can never say it right.
The concentration camp place right.
And it turns out it's in Poland and I
was like, well I don't have the time,
it's going to be too far away.
So I kind of googled some fucking pictures
of it and shit and I looked at it and
I was like, oh my God, I
could never fucking go there.
I mean literally like you're fucking blood
runs cold, like looking at this shit.
And then they had like,
you know,
pictures of like piles of
like kids shoes and shit.
And I'm literally buying shoes for
my kid and I'm just like going,
am I really bitching that I
have a three 30 fucking show?
Kind of a fucking asshole.
Am I right?
I think people eat fucking hot fudge
Sundaes. I'd do that every once in awhile.
You know what I mean?
They got to look up a bunch of starve and
fucking kids in the middle of nowhere.
Not even in the middle of nowhere,
in the middle of where the world for
whatever reason considers nowhere before
you sit there and try to like figure out
a new way to try and fuck up somebody's
career.
Cause that's going to be another thing.
This is such a weird fucking time of so
many goddamn people like they just keep
trying to like,
I keep looking at it like a bike race.
Like they try to get behind somebody
who has like a legitimate complaint.
Like I gotta be honest with you,
the fact that white women can fucking
use the term white male privilege and
they're like a white woman in
the United States of America.
The fact that they can some out hop on
the other side of the fence as some sort
of like, you know, um, underprivileged
group. And I'm not saying that,
you know, they don't get less than
white males, but it's just like,
should I really be listening
to your complaints next?
Are you really going to be first in line?
You actually have white privilege when
it comes to complaining because people
are going to pay attention to your shit
first even though you're suffering the
least.
Right.
As far as my complete lack of research
goes as far as me babbling here fucking
four in the goddamn morning in and really
help us on that week and somebody up
mumbling here. Um, anyways,
so I guess that's the latest thing
that can get you to not fucking,
I dunno, sell some tickets on
the road or fucking, you know,
host an awards show, like whatever
the fuck we're going to do. You know,
you know what blows my mind about
that whole ward show scandal is,
I just love how whatever was said was
said around 2011 and all these adults who
were well old enough,
well old enough work were plenty old
enough to have gotten offended back then
and made a big stink. And for some
reason it doesn't fucking come out.
It's almost like they get you on
something. They're like, all right,
hold onto that card.
You know what I mean?
Like they're playing granny fucking
water and then they wait till you get
something big enough that's going to
shine a light in their cars and then they
come back and they fucking try and
slam it down on the fucking table. Um,
I was out of the country,
but as far as what I read,
Ellen degenerate as cool and my book for
the rest of the fucking time, you know,
and I thought whatever she
was trying to do was a, is,
is the way to go about stuff like that
where you just don't try to fucking
destroy somebody. You try to
get them to see your point,
try to get people on your side to be,
hey, give this person another chance.
You have to be open like that.
You open it up to a discussion and then
people just watch it and learn some shit
rather than just being like, this person
said this, now they can't have that.
Now let's watch them fucking,
you know, lose something.
You know who she's just sitting there
watching it for the fucking entertainment
value. Um, this is one of
my favorite things to do.
By the way is to get on my fucking high
horse here and preach at a quarter to
four in the fucking morning, whatever
fucking time at is here. Um, all right,
let's talk a NFL playoffs.
I missed most of them.
I was able to watch a little bit
of that eagles bears game, um,
in German, which was pretty
cool. Um, cause they kept
enough for the English words,
um, that I was able to, you know,
kind of know what the fuck they
were talking about. And uh,
I know everybody's going
to get on the bears kicker,
but can somebody please explain to me
why the fuck you go for a two point
conversion?
When the bears did that,
why not just fucking kick the Goddamn
thing and then you end up losing by one?
John Madden my entire fucking
life said you take the points,
you take the points, you take the points,
those extra points come back to haunt.
Yet, I know this guy, I missed it.
I guess he hit a number of
fucking goalposts and hit
the CROC goalpost and the
crossbar. And the last one,
I watched the highlights,
but why the fuck are you going for
two points there? Makes it just,
you know,
well choose your only up by two.
You're acting like it's the end of the
game with the fucking two minutes to go
is a whole bunch of time left.
And I forget when it happened,
the end of the third quarter,
beginning of fourth quarter,
but there was plenty of fucking time
where it's a complete non factor.
Just take that extra fucking point,
just take the fucking thing and then
see where the fuck you are with the last
five minutes.
Then you start playing that game.
You know everybody's going
like Patrick one now.
Like pull in the fucking goalie would
like 10 minutes left in the game,
which for some reason I actually worked
for him. So congratulations to uh,
to the eagles, to nick
falls, man. I, by the way,
they'll match matched
bisky man out of Trump,
Friskies 80 then you had a fucking break
game through for over hundred yards.
Um,
I thought he was like really accurate and
he was dealing with like the defending
super bowl champions that thought it
was great to Nick's falls is that guy,
you know, like I just
fucking delivers. Um,
oh my God. Pete Carroll. Jesus
Christ for fucking bastard.
The poor fucking bastard man.
He's getting a ton of shit in Seattle.
I guess they thought he ran the ball too
much and uh, I don't know what happened.
That field goal kicker got fucking hurts
and then they have to punch her there
and he has to do an onside kick. Like
why didn't he just do what they all do?
Just stick it on the tee
and then he kicked the ball
in a downward motion on the
upper third of the fucking ball. So it
pops up in the air. Yeah. The guy just,
he fucking just fucking basically
lobbed it down the field that you know
something.
Okay.
If Pete Carroll never won a Superbowl
and they were going to make a statue of
him,
it would be him with his hands on his
fucking knees just looking down at the
ground in pain.
He sort of the urban
Meyer of a NFL coaches,
you know, and that they both won,
but they just have that fucking,
they just have that, that's soul crushing.
Whenever I see him do that. You don't,
it reminds me of,
it reminds me of Carl
Yastrzemski when he backed me,
he's backing up to the wall.
When Bucky dent hit that three run
homer and you just saw his legs buckle.
It just reminds me of that every
time I see that shit. So, um,
I dunno, my condolences. I don't usually
have condolences to Seattle fans,
but I dunno, the rivalries kind of died
down. You football fans, I feel for you.
I've been there and all that
shit. Um, congratulations.
San Diego chargers and I forget who
played the last game or the colts.
I guess the colts look good
and Andrew luck is back,
which is great.
Um,
other than that, I haven't been
fucking doing anything here.
I should probably do
some of these reeds here.
This podcast might be a
little short because I have
to get up, go to the airport.
I'm already up. All right. Oh,
look who's here. I can't do this.
Read justice everybody.
I apologize. It's old zip
recruiter.
You know what's mad?
Figuring out who you need to hire to
take care of your business to take your
business to the next level in 2019 you
know what else is SMAD stat in the new
year, I'll have strong by
going to ziprecruiter.com/berta
hire the right fucking
people.
Unlike other jobs.
I wonder if now when you go
to hire the right people,
they should add to ZipRecruiter.
It also goes through all your,
you're always a tweets you've ever sent
out to make sure someone's not going to
be like, you know, I wanted to
rent a car from this person.
And then they'd said this,
the tweet in thousand nine,
making fun of people with ugly feet.
I have feet that are,
they wouldn't say ugly.
I would they say it,
I dunno.
Visually challenged. Um,
unlike other job sites,
ZipRecruiter finds qualified
candidates for you. It's powerful.
Matching technology scans thousands of
resumes to identify people with the right
skills, education, and experience,
and actively invite them
to apply to your job.
So you get qualified candidates fast.
That's why zip
what of recruiter?
Yeah,
it's a German version is rated number
one by employers in the u s this rating
comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over 1000 reviews.
And right now my listeners can get zip.
She's a recruiter for free at this
exclusive websites, ziprecruiter.com/burr.
If you love this show,
show you support to it and zip recruiter
by going to ziprecruiter.com/bar B u.
R r that's ziprecruiter.com/bar oh Ah,
sorry. My voice is going out trying to
do the German garden. Every movie, Zip
recruiter, the smartest way to
hire. All right. Policy genius.
Um,
getting life insurance is one of the more
intimidating parts of becoming a full
fledged adult.
It's not that bad if you have kids.
It's weird if you get it and you
just have your wife, you know,
cause then you're like,
is this bet you're gonna kill me?
Once you have the kid, you let go. I
didn't want them to be all right. Sorry.
I watch a lot of those fucking first
48 and it always comes down, you know,
first time murderers. So much of it
comes down to life insurance. Uh,
am I not selling this right? Well,
right now I don't think I am.
There's so many options.
It's hard to know where to start,
but making sure your family is financially
protected is too important to avoid.
This is what you do once
you get life insurance,
you just sort of monitor
your wife's laptop or your
husbands if the checking out,
like you know how to dispose of a body
or the checking out when the tides go in
and out,
that I think you might want to
put a little addendum to your policy.
So policy genius creates a website that
makes it easy for you to compare quotes
and get advice and get covered without
extra fees or commission. A sales agent.
Motivate your audience, talk about your
experience with the product. Slash.
Service.
I've never used it,
but I got life insurance and
now whenever I hit turbulence,
when I'm flying or whatever, I don't
worry about it cause I'm like, well,
you know what? As much as they're
going to miss me, it's you know,
they're going to be, they're
going to be all right. Uh,
and the House won't be as loud.
Uh,
choose one to two copy points to
rotate into your spot. All right,
I'll read the first two.
Policy Genius is easy way to
get life insurance in minutes.
You can compare quotes from top insurance
to find the coverage you need at a
price you can afford.
From there,
you can apply online and the advisors
at policy genius will handle all the red
tape to even negotiate your
rate with the insurance company.
It's all part of their
best price guarantee.
That's great because it's a shit show
trying to find the right one. Uh,
if you've been intimidated or
frustrated by insurance in the past,
try starting your
search@policygenius.com and minutes.
You can compare quotes and apply.
You can do the whole thing
on your phone right now.
Policy Genius easiest were to
compare and buy life insurance.
Oh fuck. How am I going to do this?
Read justice with my voice here, honey.
Um,
you probably heard me talk about honey,
the free browser extension
that automatically helps
me save money on all my
favorite sites.
But did you do that?
Honey even makes Amazon
better with Millie attitude.
Fuck Amazon. Who's fucking
cons? Those assholes.
They throw it over the fence.
They consider it delivered.
There's no return address.
You never can figure out who
the fuck's sent it to you.
It's a fucking nightmare with millions
of sellers on Amazon offering the same
products. How do you know if you're
really getting the best price?
How the fuck do you know if it was
delivered? There's no fucking phone call.
You've got to bring it back down to a
shop and they're just little, little,
little flows we can tell was
delivered. We could form it. Uh,
that's where honey comes in. What is the
fucking driver said it was confirmed.
Honey automatically goes to wear to work.
Whenever I shop on Amazon,
I ordered this other shit on Amazon
is fucking, and I never got it.
I know what the fuck is.
It compares the PR.
This is like the worst
advertising read ever.
It compares the prices of every seller
that carries the item. I want honey,
even factors in shipping,
sales tax and Amazon prime status to
make sure I'm getting the lowest price.
It shows me the best delivery time,
even if Amazon doesn't.
Um, it's like having my very
own personal shopping assistant.
Of course Amazon does. If he can't
fucking get anybody on the phone,
more than 10 million people
are using honey to save money.
Honey is so has over a hundred
thousand five star reviews on Google.
Maybe I need honey, so Amazon
will work better for me. Um,
five star reviews on
the Google chrome store.
Time magazine says it's
basically free money.
So the next time you're in the
world's biggest marketplace,
looking for the best deals,
treat yourself to the free upgrade
that makes Amazon better. Add honey for
free@jointhoney.com slash bird that's
join honey.com/bar. That's hilarious.
I'm making fun of Amazon and
everything that they don't do. Well,
honey actually fixes it.
So in a way I was selling it cause God
knows we're all still gonna use Amazon.
Right? Alright, last radio a my bookie.
How the fuck he doing? Are you
doing? You fucking degenerate.
Nfl Playoffs are here and it's time
to get into the edge with my bookie.
Um, don't be that guy with no rooting
interest as your relatives or friends sit
around watching the game.
Not this year when the 53rd
super bowl is around the corner,
secretly 53. Holy. I've been
watching since Superbowl 12th.
Fucking um, it's real. It really
is the most wonderful time of year.
Make sure you're ready for the daily
action by signing up at my bookie today.
They pay fast.
When you win.
Ownership really cares about good customer
service and they offer the craziest
props. When you bet it's just as
important as who you're betting on. Oh,
where are you? Where are you? Bet is just
as important as who you're voting on.
And if you wanted to make
money during the bowl season,
you got to go to my
bookie. I trust him. Uh,
but you don't have to take my word for it.
Check them out for yourself.
Join now at my bookie.
We'll offer you a 50% deposit bonus to
make sure you have a nice bank roll. Nice.
Four can bankroll football season.
Use the Promo Code [inaudible] when
you deposit to activate the offer.
That's Promo Code Bar at my
bookie on the fucking door.
You pay you when you get paid.
All right, where am I at here?
30 fucking minutes. Shit, I
opened up getting sick here.
How much you fucking vitamins
CD you have to take. You know,
let me grab one of these goddamn packets.
Okay. Yeah, I'll drink one now. Dude.
This fucking hotel,
I can't figure out.
I can't figure out how to turn
all the fucking heat, you know.
But the one of the things,
the only thing I hate more than not being
able to turn it on on the fucking heat
is having to call down to the front desk
and then they got to send somebody up.
I just, I thought I'd rather
sit here and get sick. Um,
yeah,
we go a little bit of fucking
often Bach bottled water can be,
I can get seltzers on my podcast
to advertise a little fun with it.
See packet here.
This is how you do with,
hey, did anybody else on Twitter see
that? Hilarious little, I don't know.
Is it a Gif? Is A, is a picture. I
don't know what the fuck you call it.
You Know Bell Biv devoe somebody made one.
That was bell,
Bev and Willem default.
So it was bill bib default
and that's the kind of shit that's
the kind of shit that I fucking love.
I love that silly shift.
Um, all right Dan, we go,
AH, Christ bill Sterman it with
your finger. You fucking animal.
What is wrong with you? Um, all
right, down the hatch. Here we go.
That is a lot of stuff
fits it. Um, all right.
So anyways, yeah, so we ordered
room service as far as I can tell.
The top three things on room
service in Germany are uh,
a hamburger,
the inner schnitzel or spaghetti.
And I actually, when I was in
Munich I got some dean or Schnitzel,
which I always thought was
like a fucking hot dog,
but he's so pork cutlet that's breaded.
It was fucking delicious.
Um,
that's what's killing me about being
here in Germany as I haven't had time to
get like a proper German meal.
I've just been traveling so much and uh,
you know,
I,
I'm never going to do ancestry.com but
as far as the names of my family tree,
I know I am mostly German.
MMM.
I love this shit. I was fucking
sausages and fucking beer and all that.
It kills me. I'll tell you the
next time I come here to Germany,
which I'm definitely going to do
because it's been so much fun.
I am going to be beyond off the wagon
and I'm trying all these fucking be,
I'm going to book myself
out here in October fest.
I wouldn't buy a little BMDS Oktoberfest
outfit outfit and I'm going to fucking
drink my ass off,
but not on this tour.
Oh, Billy. No Fun. It's coming up on 50
days. Have just been a fucking douchebag.
Um, anyways, so let's plow ahead here.
Let's read some of these
fucking things for the week. Uh,
just another one about Poland.
All right.
Very excited to go to Poland to very
excited to go to bottle Berlin. All that.
Like all the rest of this tour is
just going to be just a bunch of bar.
Just a bunch of shit I'd never seen.
I would speaking to that,
guess who came out to the show last night?
Guess who the fuck showed up?
One of my favorite drummers,
one of the greatest drummers in the world.
Benny grip.
Yeah.
Showed up with his lovely girlfriend.
I hate naming names and everything,
but everybody knows who the fuck he has,
right?
MMM.
He fuck, I couldn't believe, you know,
I, it's just, it's unbelievable. Uh,
if you're a drummer out there and you
want to see somebody who possesses one of
the rare things in drumming,
which is incredible feel passion,
playing from the heart
combined with ridiculous chops.
And the thing that I've found with,
with drumming is when
you get those chops guys,
a lot of times when they play
there between their ears,
like they're in their head and they
have all this really intricate shit,
but it's disconnected to
who they are as a person.
And then if you have like a group player,
you know,
if they go to take a solo,
if they even do, it's uh,
you know, it's still good because it's
still gurus, but it's not like the crazy,
uh,
I don't know.
I'm just saying those guys that have
those fucking insane shops where you would
think even buddy rich will be going like,
dude,
what the fuck are you
doing there nowadays?
How far drumming has come because
everybody, the Internet's,
but basically everybody's
watching everybody.
Everybody's jamming and
learning from each other. Uh,
it's just so rare to meet a guide that
has his chops and plays the way he does.
So he does clinics all
around the world and uh,
he's got some DVDs out there and all in
this no fucking way that you won't be
tremendously changed for the better
if you start watching his videos.
So it's Benny Benny,
Grip B andN Y G R E B I believe.
I'm not sure if this too and I
can't fucking spell anything.
Just check them out if you
can't. All right. Anyways,
just another one about Poland.
Uh,
Dear Mc run from the sun.
I like that one. Uh, I am honestly
thrilled. Done in a few days.
You're going to show up in my nuts.
So beautiful city of Warsaw.
Don't tell me that.
Well,
they live in and out so beautiful
city of La and I love it.
I like how it's gritty and grimy
and all that shit. You know. Sorry,
drinking more phone. Let me see
here. Uh, mainly because, um, okay.
I'm honestly thrilled that you are going
to be in a few days and you're going to
show up.
It might not so beautiful city of Warsaw,
mainly because I'm selling my house and
you are so white that you're rising the
property value whenever you arrive.
Sky's all areas or
lady, let's be fair. Um,
I don't want to offend shame anybody or
whatever the fuck you were talking about
now.
Um,
but since you're kind enough to do
one of those pussy ass shows of yours,
I will definitely come. I like this
guy. Sprake and fucking balls. Um,
you, you are going to
love Poland as Yossef.
Palecki used to say it's a great nation.
Only people are constant.
Whole. Wait a minute.
Do is everybody is funny as you in Poland,
is this going to be another fucking
country I go to where I'm just like,
oh my God, these guys remind
me. The people I grew up
with, I felt that in Ireland.
I felt it in Scotland. I felt
that in India. Just that,
that Boston sharps Bobrick
and Fuckin thing is mine.
It's my favorite thing in
the world. Um, anyways,
as for the city of Warsaw,
well she's not the prettiest of Gals,
but let's be fair. That bitch, that
bitch went through some shit. Uh,
we are watching American shows,
so don't worry about making
your pop culture references.
We're currently watching Alf,
and once we figure out
why those jokes are funny,
we're going to move on to Frazier.
Dude,
can you please start doing standup
or something? This is just the, Oh,
this is just written really fucking funny.
Uh,
you can also consider renting a helicopter
here since it's much cheaper than the
u s although Polish helicopter, it's
just a horse wearing a windmill hat. Ah,
radio had one fucking Polish joke.
Doctor,
best wishes to your family and break
your PC leg on this tour. Our ps, uh,
if you're interested
in Soviet bloc history,
God knows I didn't learn about
that when I was growing up.
Then you should check a comedian
freeze love F R E Z l UV,
talking about his military service
in Berlin during the Cold War.
Um, I will definitely check that out
and I'll send out a link to this,
uh, podcast episode here.
Um, Oh, speaking of which,
I've been having the best time
with Rosie right at, for z.
The one thing I love about [inaudible]
is [inaudible] is [inaudible]. Okay.
The Way Maddie was going to be,
Maddie poverty's Rosie,
he's over here wearing his Jordans.
You know,
he's got his fucking Nike tracksuit on
and we were in Cologne, Germany. Uh,
did I tell you this yet? I've told them
on stage so many times we're living,
we're walking over this fucking
bridge right from Cologne. Germany,
as I mentioned, was one of the
most bomb cities in world war two.
So there's not a lot of old stuff
there because it just got destroyed.
But they have this one beautiful church,
right? So we're walking over the bridge.
At first he is going like, Dude,
look at that building, man. God,
it's a beautiful building.
And that building beautiful and I'm
looking at is these cluster of whatever
buildings and in the middle
of it is this amazing church.
So I'm looking at the buildings
going, what the fuck is this guy? See?
Like what building is that
building right there? Look,
it's fucking the architecture's beautiful.
And finally figured out, I was like,
dude, are you talking about the fucking
church? And he's like, yeah, that data.
Oh No, I already told this story
till the story on Thursday.
I'm still giving him shit about that.
It's a great building.
Um, all right. Oh, by the way,
Versie Versie two Sicilian in Greek.
He loved the vianor Schnitzel too.
And he's actually really enjoying,
uh, Jeremy too, which made me happy.
Cause sometimes there's
Mediterranean guys, you know,
they get all fucking upset about the
food and there's no sunshine and shit,
you know, but he's been having a great
time. All right, Gypsies. Hey there,
Billy bloated broths. Uh, I go to Romania.
Oh,
this is what I was talking about.
We're learning that Gypsy's
considered a racial slur. All right,
listen to this first sentence.
He goes,
I go to Romania frequently for work and
I'm quite versed in Gypsies and why it
is a racial slur.
Uh,
in order to love about that was
he still used the word gypsy.
That's like if I was in
America being like a,
hey everybody, uh, for when
you traveled to America,
I've been to east St Louis and I'm
quite versed in and words and why it's a
racial slur. Like I, I wouldn't do that.
That's kind of what he just did there. Uh,
first Rome Romanians are not Gypsies,
Robin people,
Romanian people are descendants of Romans.
I didn't know that Gypsies are
people that came from Egypt. Uh,
if you want to insult a Romanian
person called him a gypsy,
Gypsies stick to themselves and
rob slash steal from outsiders.
They will fight at the drop of a hat.
I saw two old lady,
Gypsies fighting over which corner they
were selling flowers on in the old city
in Bucharest. I hope this
clears it up a little. No, it,
that didn't clear anything up.
Um,
now I know that Romanians are Roman
and Gypsies are people are from Egypt.
I do know that.
And then you went on to fucking trash
him in a way that I'm sure there were
upset about. I Dunno. Jesus Christ.
Did I just get in trouble
just by fucking read that.
So they've got a lot of fight
them. All right. What are
you gonna do? I mean, we've,
I've seen these videos have to stamp
people dressed up like Santa Claus beating
the fuck out of each other
and my country. Uh, all right.
But I didn't realize that Romanians,
but almost it says Roman in there,
Huh? Did Not know that. All right.
I left to look a lot of that up.
Double check, which means I'm not
going to do it. I'll forget about it.
And then the information you just told me,
we'll be in my head in one day.
I'm going to spew it out, but I'm
probably gonna get in trouble. All right.
Recent breakup. Am I the
asshole? Well, firstly,
first of all,
first dilly.
What two words did I just,
first of all,
it's certainly, I don't know what
the fuck up. I don't know. Anyways,
my girlfriend of three years
broke up with me over something.
Me and my family thinks is stupid.
All right,
so right now I'm a little nervous here.
You know if families back in you,
you know, are you not one of those
fucking young kids that can do no wrong,
are you anyways? We are both 20 and
since last February we've been also,
what generation are you,
is that generation z?
We are both 20th since last February.
We've been arguing since we invited her
to my birthday dinner and she got upset
because she was expected to pay
for her own meal. All right. Who?
Who, who's, who's her?
Is that your girlfriend?
Okay.
I didn't tell my parents until months
later because they didn't want to start
anything. Anyway, around early December,
my family asked me to invite her to come
up with us to my dad's parents home on
the 29th because that's when we
could celebrate Christmas with them.
When I texted her, she said, am I
going to have to pay for my own gas?
I have a s d I don't know what that means.
So I assumed I was missing something.
So I do. Do you have like add
to the point that you have?
Don't have the fucking time to write
add vinegar to look up fucking ASD,
all saints disease a s d
you are not connected to the,
you are not a winner. All right.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
I don't give a shit.
I'll learn about it later. Um, I have
ASD, so I assumed I was missing something.
So I asked my dad and he said,
of course
she flipped out about it.
Oh, is as Berger's disease.
Would that be abd or is that antilock
brakes? I don't fucking know.
Uh, let's ABS. She flipped
out about it and became,
and it became the new thing we could
argue about her mom and her sister agree
with her that it's Shitty to not pay
for someone's gas when you invite them
someplace. But my dad's
parents didn't pay for our gas,
but no one we know ask for that.
And all of our family members,
we invite to be day dinners.
Never complained about
paying their own bill.
Should I put pun not intended,
I'd appreciate your advice or,
and I'm a big fan.
You seem pretty good with your response.
And most cases I should note that
after breaking up with me on new years
despite, all right, that's how we ended
it. I don't understand what's gone on it.
You guys sound like a bunch of cheap
fucking assholes greenhouse with him.
He takes somebody up for
their fucking birthday.
You make them pay for their birthday
dinner. That's fucking terrible.
It's so terrible. It's
like, it's hilarious.
And I'm sure she didn't give
a fuck about paying for gas.
She's probably alluding to the fact
that you that you've made or pay
for our own fucking birthday.
That's fucking hilarious
then in a lot of ways is sadder than
going out to dinner by yourself for your
birthday.
Cause at least nobody there at the
restaurant knows that your birthday now,
you sitting there with a table full of
people that know what your birthday and
how you got to kick in. Wow. Yeah.
I should probably stop short of calling
you and your whole family a bunch of
cheap fucks, but let's just say a
little rough around the edges. Um,
but whatever,
that's water under the bridge.
I guess you need to find your soulmate,
the kind of woman that doesn't mind
paying for her own birthday dinner. We,
you know, maybe you're
a feminist, you know,
cause most guys who we pay for
our own shit on our birthdays,
we have to go out and go buy the big
fucking fancy gift on Valentine's Day.
I don't know.
I can't figure that one out.
And the fact that you
stopped mid sentence,
like she fucking showed up your place and
club you to death and then he had sand.
So the forensics couldn't figure out
what time you died while he did send an
email. Alright. Lesbian
dating with no spark.
All right. Whatever the fuck
you're dating, if there's
no spark and out of it, uh,
he built,
I was wondering if you were near,
could give me some dating advice to
a lady listener all, unfortunately,
Nia is not here,
so you're gonna have to deal with my
dumb fucking ideas. Uh, I've been,
I've gone out on seven really good
dates with a wonderful woman who was
essentially everything I've ever looked
for in a partner. She's Hilarious,
witty, playful, beautiful, smart.
And motivated and good
kind hearted person. Um,
are you fucking my wife? Sorry.
Uh, the way we have ridiculous,
Witty Banter reminds me of how you
and Nia are on the podcast. Well,
that's what reminded me when you said it.
Uh,
it turns out we even want all the same
things in life in terms of a long term
relationship. How does this go
left? Did you finally get her naked?
She had a dick. I mean, what is, what
is going on here? Uh, wanting a family,
living close to parents and siblings
in the same area we grew up. However,
in the past few days she's grown
a little distant. Uh, Jesus,
when I asked her why,
she explained that although she really
enjoys spending time with me and then I
have done nothing wrong, she's never felt
strong, passionate feelings toward me.
Uh, okay. This is how you
got to walk somebody through
their feelings. Oh, ahead.
This is never fun.
I responded honestly that I have not
necessarily felt that huge passive spark.
Oh, wait a minute. I read it wrong.
Oh,
okay.
She said she never felt strong,
passionate feelings toward me.
Oh, I thought you meant she's never felt
that before and she was scared that she
loves you. So she's saying like,
you're cool but I'm not failing.
I responded honestly that I have not
necessarily Sara's Sara Lee felt that huge
past exparte with her either.
Well congratulations.
What you guys have on your hands
is, is your your fuck buddies. Okay.
And now where you're in an area of limbo
and we don't really know where to go
from here.
I think it's clear that we are attracted
to each other and very compatible,
but there is a lack of clear
chemistry between us. Uh,
she has an decelerated online
class for the next two weeks,
so we decided to cool things down and
meet again after that is finished.
I think that's very wise.
My question is if you
consider an emotional,
passionate drive necessarily necessary
for two people to be together
successfully long term and
how it was with you when Nia,
I am personally a believer in longterm
love growing over time and that put
passionate love and my
experience generally follows
the Newtonian rule of what
comes up. Must always come
down lovely wishes to you,
Nia, and that your little
one and go fuck yourself. Um,
I think that the fact that you guys both
had that really mature conversation,
neither one of you feeling a spark. It's
just like, you know, in the beginning,
if there's the spark,
there's that,
that's that euphoria that you kind of
chase for the rest of your relationship
because you know,
you just get used to each other and then
when the love comes out,
it's usually vacation holiday or if
you've been through something together and
you survived,
it brings you closer together.
And then you have like these memories.
MMM.
You know, like I've gone
through rough periods, you know,
with my wife and like having a kid
just upsets the whole apple cart and,
uh,
you're focusing so much on the kid that
you can kind of like forget to check in
with each other. And, um, you know,
so when I've learned with her as we
have to take like these little weekend
vacations, you know, in town, just
go to a hotel and it's hilarious.
And then we instantly
fall back in love again.
And then spend the rest of the time
looking at pictures of our daughter,
seeing how we miss her and stuff.
So,
um, I dunno, I think
because you guys have, you guys seem
like you should be really good friends,
but the weirdest thing is you
already banged or whatever.
So I don't know how that
works in the lesbian world,
but I know in the a Hetero
world that can get weird
and it's kind of 50, 50,
sometimes the guy gets weird.
Sometimes the woman gets weird. It's
just kind of weird. So I don't know.
I think it's probably a good thing that
you guys aren't going to see each other
for a couple of weeks and you
can kind of be like, you know,
cause it's early on. Just see where
the fuck you are after two weeks.
But um,
I dunno, I think you're doing it right,
but like I know anything about that Shit,
you know?
Yeah.
Which is why he probably
asked me to chime in to, um,
to be honest with you,
the only way that it's
going to fucking work is a,
is it,
you do have that spark in the beginning
because that sparks is what's gonna make
you stay.
Cause if you don't have that spark and
you get married for the fucking reasons
or whatever, that it's
just like, you know,
you see people marry for money in this
sitting on a fucking yacht and they're
miserable. Uh, all grown
man's sitting while pissing,
oh Jesus Christ.
It's one of the worst images I've
ever heard dear. Oh, Billy blue hills.
Um, I'm a 40 year old man
with three young children.
I realized the other day that over the
past couple of years I've been sitting
down when I piss more off the,
the not all right.
Now this is funny cause if you're
doing it because you're tired,
it's just fucking hilarious.
I was worried that you were going to,
this is going to be some other
progressive thing that, you know,
standing, Piss, privileged, whatever the
fuck they're going to come up with next.
Um,
it all started when the kids were babies.
My wife would wake up to feed and I would
head down to the canned like a Zombie
to piss and I was too damn
tired to standard aim.
Now the kids are a little older and I'm
still fucking exhausted most of the time
at home that I find myself
sitting down to piss all the time.
I think of just tired as fuck.
Am I crazy to assume this is common
among thing among men my age with young
children now that you are 50, do you do
the same? I can't be the only one. Right.
Thanks. Love the podcast and go
fuck yourself. No, I don't do that.
The only time they ever do that is if
my wife's sleeping and where we lived in
smaller apartments. I didn't want to
wake her up when I was taking a Piss,
you know,
on a consideration I would sit down and
that would always make me laugh and I
would always picture all of my friends
making fun of me that I was sitting down.
Well, well piss it. Uh,
I think the fact that you still
say pacing rather than paying,
which is one of my major pet peeves.
Uh,
I can meet with a guy says
I have to go pee. It just,
I can't even tell you my body like
microscope of lead, like could torch.
MMM.
Oh by the way, somebody told me
it's anyway and not any ways.
And I have to tell you, I don't
give a shit. I like say it anyways.
I say the plural sense.
Uh,
no you probably not the
only one who does it.
Uh,
but I will tell you that
what I have learned just having one
kid is how important it is to get eight
hours of really good sleep.
And you shouldn't watch TV
and be on your fucking phone.
I've actually gone back to reading. If you
consider reading sports books, reading,
I try to read that my wife,
she always watches the fucking real
housewives or that tattoo parlors show,
you know,
any show that involves people.
She doesn't care about screaming
at each other for some reason.
She loves to watch that
before she goes to bed. Um,
so I just put on these, the, the,
the fucking same headphones
I wear when I fly in a plane,
so I can't hear people and I
just read the fucking book.
Uh, but anyways, I think maybe if
you get eight hours sleep, yeah,
you hit the gym a little
bit if you have time.
But I know how tired I am with one kid.
I can't imagine with like three and
a good friend of my life, totally.
One time when he was talking about
being a parent, his kids are older,
he's got like two or three kids
and three kids and he said,
uh, he goes, dude, he goes,
I've been tired since the 90s.
So I think that's just what it is.
Uh,
that's just what it is that you know what
it is because once your kids get older
and they can kind of take care of
themselves, meaning they can wake up,
brush their teeth,
get ready for school and all that,
you feel like you're
not going to be tired.
But I think the thing that makes you
tired is the worry because you constantly
fucking worried that something's going
to happen to him. But whatever. Um,
all right, that's the podcast. Apologize
for the low volume of talking here.
I really want to everybody that's
come out to my shows here in Germany,
I could not have had a better
time. Uh, it was fucking awesome.
And, uh, I will definitely be
back the next time. Hopefully
when I get a new hour,
you guys still want to come to see me?
I will definitely be back.
I think I'll come during
the summer months,
next time or Octoberfest one or the other.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves then. I'll
check in on yet. Thursday.